It's not single mothers raise criminals.
It's fathers abandoned their children
and mothers do their best with what they got going on.
Can't focus on the one parent that stayed and was doing something
and then talk shit about the results.
Why don't we talk about
and focus on the men that are abandoning their children,
impregnating women with no intention of ever raising that baby,
using children as a weight and, like,
a burden to, like,
Mark their territory with women and, like,
knock them off the shelf, so to speak.
Like, it's disgusting.
It's disgusting and it's disgusting,
and we're not gonna let the focus get fucking muddled here.
It's not the fact that the children were raised by single mothers.
Purpose of that statistic and that study
was to point out where we could put more resources.
And that means
men could actually step up and support the fucking children
that they created just as much as the woman.